[Música]
era uma vez eu entrei na faculdade de
direito e eu me apaixonei pelo curso era
a segunda oportunidade que eu tinha de
entrar numa graduação
a primeira descobri que eu tinha entrado
na hora errada no momento errado e que
não era o meu perfil
então não havia encontrado a minha outra
metade que era o direito à eu estava
apaixonada era ali que era o meu lugar
era ali que eu me via no futuro a minha
profissão estava ali no direito não
interessava se eu fosse advogada juíza
promotora independente do que fosse eu
estava muito satisfeita em cursar
direito
e assim iniciou o curso o tempo foi
andando e com o tempo a gente tem as
aulas práticas têm os estágios têm as
monitorias né é nessas desses estágios
fomos convidados a participar de uma
aula de direito digital
eu achei muito interessante porque além
de gostar muito de direito a computação
sempre chamava minha atenção à área da
tecnologia casava com direito era algo
que eu gostava e eu fui chegando lá o
professor brilhava e eu nossa é que é o
meu lugar eu vou crescer é aqui e ele
começou a apresentar é como que
funcionava tecnologia do direito é
explicou sobre o processo é judicial
eletrônico ensinou pra gente como usar o
software e eu fiquei apaixonada falei
pronto é que eu fico
e aí eu comecei a pesquisar e eu no
final dessa desse estágio é desse dia de
estágio que foi específico pra o direito
digital eu falei com ele professou eu
quero ficar aqui ele olhou pra mim e
falou assim aproveita porque daqui uns
dias o seu trabalho vai ser feito por
robôs
e eu como assim eu estava na faculdade
eu estava apaixonada pelo curso já tinha
avançado muito eu tinha certeza que eu
estava no curso certo
na hora certa e que eu ia ser feliz ea
prosperar ali mas não e descobrir que
estava sendo estudar eu estava estudando
para ser substituída por oba pensa você
estudar tanto tempo gastar tanto tempo
lendo escrevendo pesquisando e
diversificando de todas as formas
possíveis o estudo pra vocês é
simplesmente substituído no futuro e
aquilo me provocou um sentimento muito
grande de angústia como que poderia
crescer aquele tempo todo na faculdade
tem aprendido tanto gostar tanto do meu
curso mas simplesmente não têm um futuro
interessante e foi bem nessa época aí
nessa época de angústia que eu acho que
se a gente mas eu paro o meu curso e
começa outro curso esses outros cursos
que a itália foi a outra formação também
não formação de futuro
e foi exatamente o que eu passei a
pesquisar e me remeteu ao que foi a
revolução industrial
não sei se você se recorda mas a
primeira revolução industrial ela
substituiu a força do homem e dos
animais pela força mecânica ele muitas
profissões foram embora e essas
profissões que for embora elas tiveram
de se readequar porque a força mecânica
já realizava avançando um pouquinho mais
teve uma segunda revolução industrial
que foi quando a indústria passou a usar
a energia elétrica e também o petróleo
ou seja mais uma vez teve uma evolução
muito grande nas profissões foi bem
nessa época foi criado o telégrafo e o
telefone onde as possibilidades de
informação de informação passou a ser
muito mais rápido mas adiante teve a
terceira revolução industrial essa aqui
já fui nascido após a segunda guerra
mundial onde foi criada na internet o
computador e aí as redes começou a
crescer a prosperar e as informações que
antes lá na primeira revolução
industrial eram mínimas
elas passaram a ser mais rápidas mais
velozes
e destruindo outras profissões eu sempre
digo a o progresso da tecnologia da
indústria serve para destruir profissões
inclusive a minha
e agora nós estamos vivendo a quarta
revolução industrial
e essa quarta revolução industrial ela
está marcada pela tecnologia essa
tecnologia ela vai pra mudar
ela vai trazer uma nova roupagem e foi
exatamente essa essa quarta revolução
industrial que me tirou o meu emprego
foi aqui que eu vim formei fui lá
bonitinho e descobrir que não têm
emprego
minha profissão não existe e foi a
partir desse momento que eu passei até
mais angústia ainda e pronta agora que
não tem emprego eu preciso fazer alguma
coisa de interessante na vida
já no finalzinho da faculdade eu
descobri que a pessoa queria me
substituir se chamar watson
essa é uma tecnologia muito interessante
da ibm que ela é cognitivo é uma
plataforma cognitiva você ensina ela e
ela faz tudo que você quer na área do
direito especificamente watson ele
consegue ler em um segundo
mais de um bilhão de documentos eu lhes
mortal
não sei quantos anos da minha vida
gastaria pra ler essa quantidade toda de
documentos aí que eu percebi que eu não
tenho um emprego mais
então vamos mais pra frente e eu
descobri que o hotel na realidade era
uma tecnologia que não era minha inimiga
não era inimiga da minha profissão não
só do dundee no âmbito do direito mas da
medicina da no ramo da hotelaria da de
no ramo também de da indústria todas
essas profissões ligadas à ao mecanismo
elas iriam ser substituídas entre aspas
porém o ótimo ele ele veio pra
transformar para trazer uma nova
roupagem desse tipo d
pra esse tipo de de profissão
portanto eu percebi que aqui é quando lá
em toronto eles criaram rossi foi o
primeiro robô é advogado que ele pode
ler aquela quantidade de documentos foi
aquele alvoroço todo e não percebi nesse
momento que não era ali que eu perdi a
minha profissão era ali que eu ia ter um
companheiro e esse companheiro que eu
queria era exatamente o que aconteceu
com charlotte homes e o seu amigo doutor
watson os nomes até lembram é um
clássico da literatura
com certeza todos vocês conhecem e
percebem que o charlotte home era o
melhor investigador
ele era parte brilhante da dupla ele
pensava ele era astuto ele buscava ele
questionava ele era parte central
já o doutor watson olhar aquate vant e
assim será também com o direito do
futuro é o direito do futuro será
remetido ao que o sherlock holmes é e
por outro lado a nossa tecnologia que
foi desenvolvida pela ibm e que já está
em operação até mesmo aqui no brasil ele
será meramente coadjuvante como um
código code código coadjuvante na
maneira que ao passo que perderíamos
tempo lendo procurando pesquisando eu
vou ter um software para fazer isso pra
mim e quem vai treiná lo e cerro ele vai
está a voz que eu quero ele vai ter
ele vai ser treinado para encontrar os
tipos de documentos que eu quero e ele
eu vou utilizar meu tempo ou seja eu vou
ter o melhor do choro watson do meu lado
e você o melhor lobby homes dele mas com
toda essa evolução é importante frisar
que pra advocacia por direito para a
medicina é inevitável que a tecnologia
continue avançando e é importante que
não entraremos a ela como algo negativo
e sim como
parceira como algo positivo que só vem
trazer o que é bom
aqui no brasil o maior escritório de
advocacia
eles compraram essa tecnologia e colocar
o nome dela de carol hoje carol ela faz
mais de 100 infecções por dia sozinha
o advogado coloca com o tema ele
alimentou a plataforma e ele a carol
simplesmente dá pra ele todas as
petições todas as ações todas as
contestações carol sabe de todas as leis
brasileiras
um segundo após ser postada no site do
planalto carol já sabe
então da mesma maneira que também com a
medicina é que um é que o médico vai
poder ver ali no hospital terá acesso a
vários artigos científicos em tempo real
do mesmo jeito também vai ser um direito
mas é importante notar que essa
tecnologia ela não vai ter o calor
humano o que é esse calor humano esse
calor humano é nunca em hipótese alguma
o watson mesmo ensinando ele ele não vai
ser conseguida a apatia ou empatia das
pessoas
ele não vai conseguir saber se a pessoa
está chorando não ele não vai saber qual
é o problema da mãe que está procurando
assessoria jurídica é porque o filho não
está na escola porque o filho está
doente e não consegue
o atendimento médico infelizmente a
tecnologia não tenho sentimentos que nós
humanos têm portanto eu finalizo aqui
dizendo que a tecnologia o direito do
futuro e principalmente watson ele veio
para agregar
ele veio para ser parceiro e não pra ser
um inimigo
então é toda essa parte de conhecimento
que a gente tem hoje ela vai ser
ampliada pela tecnologia que nos é
apresentada e dessa maneira vai andar
junto com com nós humanos
então é a internet de coisas
ela hoje como é que como já é todos
conhecem temos acesso já as primeiras ao
que o 5g traz pra gente né
é quando há uma parte física é conectado
à internet então isso nos dá um certo
medo que também é produto do office on
mas isso não significa que essas
tecnologias vai sair algo ruim pra gente
enfim é temos aqui com a gente o melhor
companheiro conforme eu fiz a aac pra
vocês
a ilustração então o futuro está aí e
ele vai ser brilhante nós temos nosso
melhor amigo que a tecnologia